[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 c'est parti pour le
sommaire de ce magazine confinement le
sport amateur évinois sont encore à
l'arrêt pendant au minimum quatre
semaines certaines activités sportives
pourrait ne pas reprendre avant 2021 les
détails dans cette émission voile louis
burton originaire de rambouillet va
participer à son troisième vendée globe
il partira ce dimanche depuis les sables
d'olonne aborde son imoca bureau vallée
2 le skipper répondre à toutes nos
questions à distance dans cette émission
cyclisme la 21e et dernière étape du
tour de france 2000 21 s'élancera depuis
les yvelines après rambouillet
mantes-la-jolie c'est la ville de chatou
qui a été retenu par les organisateurs
faut plus dans ce magazine
je vous disais dans les titres ce
nouveau confinement qui devrait durer au
minimum pendant quatre semaines va
également avoir un impact sur le sport
amateur
les compétitions vont une nouvelle fois
être à l'arrêt pendant plusieurs
semaines et certains sports pourrait ne
pas reprendre avant 2021
les explications et réactions à montage
de sandrine fontaine
bis repetita pour le sport amateur ce
nouveau confinement va une nouvelle fois
perturbé la pratique sportive pendant au
minimum quatre semaines pour les sports
l'intérieur la fédération française de
handball avait été l'une des premières a
été la compétition au moins jusqu'en
décembre
tout comme la fédération française de
volley-ball pour le basket les
compétitions stop également jusqu'à
cette période mais les dirigeants
s'attendent à un redémarrage des
compétitions pour le début d'année
prochaine
la fédération de basket à au moins dit
qu' il y aurait une inertie de quinze
jours quand les rencontres pourrait
reprendre pour permettre aux équipes de
se ré entraîner les deux manières assure
une certaine équité sportive et surtout
une intégrité physique de la part de
tous les sportifs qu'il gèle à quelques
sous quel que soit le niveau auquel ils
jouent pour le football ce mercredi
matin la fédération française a annoncé
la suspension des compétitions de ligue
2 districts des championnats nationaux
d'une nationale 2 et 3 ainsi que la
coupe de france et les championnats
nationaux jeunes
cette mesure s'appliquera au minimum
jusqu'au 1er décembre un casse tête en
vue pour les instances ça pose la
question n'a pas encore pris de décision
mais
on va y réfléchir maintenant c'est les
coupes parce qu'on a les championnats la
côte est mais les coupes des yvelines
d'autre part on avait déjà les coupes
les coupes futsal
qui étaient les comme futsal seniors qui
avait dont il avait été décidé qu'elle
n'aurait pas lieu maintenant la question
va se poser pour l'ensemble des coupes
de toutes les catégories des seniors les
u18 les u16 les u14 des féminines et
c'est parce qu'il va falloir sans doute
se consacrer uniquement au championnat
le rugby amateur se met également en
pause jusqu'à début janvier au minimum
la fédération a également annoncé
l'annulation des phases finales pour
permettre aux championnats de se jouer
jusqu'au bout pour éviter la saison
blanche nous faisions contre faut de
mauvaise fortune bon coeur en ayant là
encore la possibilité de jouer désormais
il faut vous participer à l'effort
national
le plus dur reste à venir maintenant de
rester compétitif de garder le contact
avec nos licenciés nos partenaires seule
interrogation la pratique ou non du
sport par les mineurs il pourrait
participer à des entraînements
le sujet est encore sur la table nous
allons maintenant prendre le large dans
cette émission le départ du vendée globe
2020 sera donné ce dimanche depuis les
sables d'olonne un évinois participera
cette édition louis burton originaire de
robbie rambouillet s'alignera pour la
troisième fois sur cette course mythique
et louis burton est avec nous à distance
bonsoir l'ouverture bonsoir à tous
j'espère vous montant des biens
on vous entend bien alors comment vous
sentez-vous à la proche du départ c'est
un peu particulier là je suis à un petit
6 jours du départ du vendée globe et je
suis tranquillement dans ma maison avec
mon épouse mes enfants confinés
donc c'est très particulier en dix ans
de carrière c'est la première fois que
ça arrive
finalement ça a du bon parce que
d'habitude on est dans le rush du départ
et là on a le temps de se reposer et de
penser à plein de choses
oui justement vous êtes dans une bulle
c'est bien ça commence à comment ça se
passe qu'est ce qui change par rapport à
d'habitude
finalement alors le départ du vendée
globe comme beaucoup de courses au large
c'est d'abord un grand village une
grande fête
à terre pendant plusieurs semaines pour
le vendée globe ça dure quasiment un
mois
là il ya eu ce village qui s'est tenu
quand même mais qui a dû fermer ses
portes suite aux annonces
gouvernementales de la fin de semaine
dernière qui a eu deux semaines de
villages avec des accès à ces à ces
contrôles et donc il ya eu du monde un
peu mais c'était moins la folie que
d'habitude donc ça c'est un premier gros
changement
et puis ce qui va changer énormément
depuis depuis vendredi dernier c'est que
finalement on va prendre le départ du
vendée globe avec juste autour de notre
équipe technique
il y aura pas la foule qui a d'habitude
sur les quais du des sables d'olonne sur
le ponton du départ les bateaux
accompagnateurs ne vont pas être
autorisés non plus alors d'habitude il
ya une armada pas possible en mer et là
on va partir vraiment beaucoup plus dans
la confidentialité
un peu comme pour un départ de premier
vendée globe il ya trente ans alors on
va revenir à la course ce sera donc
votre troisième participation vous avez
connu différents scénarios dans votre
carrière en 2012 vous avez abandonné
assez rapidement après avoir percuté un
chalutier en 2017 vous aviez par contre
terminé à la 7e place une très belle
septième place
est ce que vous avez appris de ces deux
courses alors c'est vrai que la première
première apprentissage c'est déjà de
réussir à être au départ du vendée
c'est un rêve de gosse c'est c'est pas
accessible facilement donc les
conditions dans lesquelles on a fait le
vendée globe en 2012 avec l'équipe en
tant que première expérience ça nous a
beaucoup appris sur sur les choses à
faire et puis aussi les choses à ne pas
faire et puis les chèque l'échec ça
permet aussi d'apprendre plein de choses
de se remettre en question et puis on a
réussi à se sa ligne et sur l'édition
2016 2017 que j'ai terminé donc ça a
permis de se guérir
ça a permis de voir du coup ce qui
marche et ce qui marchait pas et des
trucs sur lesquels il fallait être
attentif et puis là j'ai la chance de
d'être avec bureau vallée de mon nouveau
bateau depuis quatre ans et je le
connais bien maintenant j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses dessus et c'est vrai
que ces 10 années d'expérience et et ses
trois participations consécutives c'est
de bonne augure
qu'est ce qui change justement et que
bureau vallée 2 ce sont les feuilles
principalement oui c'est ça le bateau
fait deux tonnes de moins déjà donc il
va à la base beaucoup plus vite
il faut certes nos bateaux ils font
entre 7 et 9 tonnes
et puis on assez folle donc ces espèces
de dell du sous marine qui permet au
bateau de se lever et du coup
d'accélérer d'aller beaucoup plus vite
qu'avant justement vous irait beaucoup
plus vite c'est quoi l'objectif cette
année
vous aviez terminé 7e la dernière fois
ouais c'est ça la dernière fois 7e au 87
jours et mon bateau actuel qui avait
fait l'édition précédente il avait misé
74 jours donc elle est mis treize jours
de moins donc bon c'est énorme
évidemment alors fonction des conditions
météo l'objectif ce serait de passer
sous la barre des 75 jours et ça on
n'est jamais sûr c'est la météo mais par
contre essayer de faire une place mieux
que la dernière fois donc ça veut dire
entre premier 6e finalement c'est le
skipper ou c'est le bateau qui fait la
course c'est ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent le skipper oui c'est important
le skipper et et sa machine est aussi sa
fiabilité
et puis il faut un peu de réussite c'est
une aventure c'est une course mais c'est
une aventure assez folles autour du
monde
malgré le fait que les marins soit super
préparer qu'on prépare ça pendant des
mois et des mois et des mois il ya
toujours que en moyenne un sur deux qui
arrive donc faut déjà arriver être du
bon côté de la balance
ce sera donc votre troisième édition est
ce qu'il y à des pièges à éviter
peut-être sur un oui vous je pense qu'il
faut éviter
il faut éviter d'être trop dans
l'excitation du départ être trop dans
dans l'excitation de d'aller tout de
suite plus vite que les autres et de du
coup de se mettre dans le rouge de
mettre son saut sa machine dans le rouge
son bateau dans le rouge il faut arriver
à se gérer sur la
sur la longueur et et que de petits
incidents ne se transforme pas en
accident ou un sur accident c'est ça
c'est un piège dans lequel il faut pas
tomber il faut faut maintenir son bateau
est soi-même au maximum de sa
performance et au niveau du parcours est
ce qu'il y à des endroits un peu clé on
pense aux poteaux noir par exemple au
large de l'afrique au niveau au niveau
de l'équateur
ce sera le peut-être le point le plus
difficile peut-être votre périple ou pas
du tout c'est pas forcément plus
difficile mais c'est vrai que quand on
pense à faire le tour de la planète à la
voile
on pourrait imaginer qu'on est dans un
film genre pirates des caraïbes ou
arrivé au bout d'un moment on tombe
alors là c'est pas le cas évidemment
parce que la planète est ronde mais il
ya partout autour du globe des zones
très compliqué à naviguer et dans le
pot-au-noir mais disons que ça c'est
plus une ues c'est plus une étape ont
potentiellement on peut perdre des
places ou en gagner si on est chanceux
mais non ce qui est très compliqué ça va
être le grand sud autour de
l'antarctique où il ya beaucoup de
dépression une météo qui est très forte
et pas mal d'embûches des icebergs qui
peuvent venir à travers de la route des
cétacés
et puis une météo et des dépressions
très chargé il faut être vigilant tout
au long du parcours filant réfo être
concentré il faut faut essayer de
rentrer dans cette zone là qui espèce de
longs tunnels de 25 joueurs en étant
100% de sa forme et avec un bateau à
100% de son potentiel
dernière question louis burton qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter et ben ne pas
me voir avant la mi janvier
on vous le souhaite en tout cas merci
louis burton bon courage pour ce vendée
globe 2020 on continuera évidemment vous
suivre sur tv à 78 une entreprise
versaillaise va également vivre les
aventures de ce1 vendée globe l'agent
spotify spécialisée dans l'aide à
domicile aux personnes âgées a décidé de
devenir l'un des sponsors du skipper
clément giro un navigateur qui sera au
départ de la compétition sables d'olonne
une idée qui est venu juste après le
premier confinement l'écoutent philippe
delmas le directeur de l'entreprise
il était au micro de tv 78 je suis un
peu tombé par hasard sur une publication
de clément giro qui est donc le skipper
du
bateau qui avait perdu son sponsor qui
avait perdu son bateau lors d'un
incendie et c'était un peu comme une
bouteille à la mer qui avait été qui
avaient été envoyés par clément j'étais
assez sensibles à son message
ça correspondait assez bien à ce qu'on
recherchait est lui aussi à des valeurs
de partage des valeurs d'engagement qui
sont très fortes
la problématique de la perte d'autonomie
est aussi une problématique qu'il
connaît bien
dans sa famille proche voilà donc on
s'est tout de suite très bien entendus
et on a décidé de le suivre
un mot de rugby à présent coup de
projecteur sur l'un des plus grand
espoir français au poste de demi
d'ouverture son nom léobard est
originaire du chéné au concours il joue
actuellement à 18 ans au stade français
après avoir fait ses premières classes à
versailles à un reportage de nicolas
landry il a choisi le club aux 14
bouclier de brennus le versaillais au
bar et a signé un contrat de deux ans
avec le stade français paris
à 18 ans elle rejoint les espoirs du
club parisien en provenance de massy
c'est quand même le club de la capitale
j'ai grandi en région parisienne j'ai
commencé à versailles on parlait du
stade français comme comme l'un des plus
gros clubs de top 14
donc j'avais comment parler de cette
france et quand j'étais petit j'avais
des étoiles dans les yeux
donc voilà ça représente ça représente
beaucoup pour moi ce jour-là léobard et
s'entraîne avec l'équipe professionnelle
sous les ordres du tacticien argentin
gonzalo quesada un moyen d'accélérer sa
progression
c'est un joueur intelligent et il est
très intelligent il
il a un gros coup de pied je pense qu'il
ya une bonne et une bonne organisation
s'il faut qu'il continue comme ça c'est
très bien on a évidemment identifié un
potentiel intéressant chez lui et puis
il a la capacité de remplir les
plusieurs cases évidemment celle du
joueur de rugby mais aussi celle du
joueur capable de mener à la fois un
projet sportif et un projet
universitaire l'idée c'est plutôt de le
faire mature et de lui donner les moyens
de s'inscrire dans la durée dans cette
équipe et d'en faire dans les deux à
trois prochaines années le demi
d'ouverture du stade français depuis
plusieurs années les au bar et participe
aussi à des stages en équipe de france
jeunes à marcoussis avec les meilleurs
joueurs français de sa génération
pendant une semaine en octobre 47
joueurs se sont retrouvés après
plusieurs mois suite à la crise
sanitaire
elles sont plutôt bonnes pour l'instant
j'arrive à retrouver un peu mes repères
que j'avais l'année dernière après je
n'arrive pas non plus à un terrain où je
connais personne enfin là je connais
quand même tous les joueurs on est
vraiment un groupe
donc on l'a vite des rebonds retrouve
vite les repères pour le rugbyman yves
binois issus de la formation versaillais
sa carrière se poursuit en équipe de
france moins de 20 ans jeu de mouvement
vitesse de circulation du ballon prise
d'initiative des qualités que les au bar
et possède et doit développer les eaux a
des qualités qui lui permet d'être
performant sur plusieurs postes
il a des qualités de franchisseur et la
qualité de passeur donc donc forcément
ce qui peut ce que l'on recherche et ce
qui peut amener l'équipe de france
mauvais à performer léobard hypostyle
pour une prochaine rencontre si la
situation sanitaire le permet début
janvier l'équipe de france moins de 20
ans développement doit jouer un match
contre l'italie
on va maintenant parler à cyclisme nous
vous l'annoncions la semaine dernière
l'information a été confirmée ce
week-end la 21e et dernière étape du
tour de france 2000 21 partira depuis
chatou dans les yvelines le 18 juillet
prochain le peloton s'élancera de cette
commune de 31 mille habitants pour
rejoindre les champs-elysées au
programme 112 km ou un sprinteur devrait
une nouvelle fois s'imposer pour nous
parler de ce choix de chatou nous
recevons sur ce plateau jean michel
richefort vice-président fédération
française de cyclisme est également club
de vélizy 78
bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce que ce
choix de chatou est une surprise
non ce n'est pas une surprise dans la
mesure où chatou c'est une
une ville sportive une ville cycliste
avec un très bon club le team cycliste
de château qui participent régulièrement
sur des épreuves régionales et des
épreuves nationales
non c'est un excellent choix et je pense
que nous aurons une belle dernière étape
avec une boucle qui passera bien sûr
dans les yvelines
et puis avec l'apothéose sur les
champs-elysées on n'a pas encore tous
les détails sur sur le parcours mais ça
serait probablement une boucle dans les
yvelines c'est bien ça oui je pense que
ce sera une boucle dans les yvelines qui
passera vraisemblablement on ne connaît
pas exactement les lieux mais on suppose
que ça ça fera une boucle en passant par
la vallée de chevreuse avant de regagner
les champs-elysées alors la ville de
château avait déjà organisé le
paris-nice en 2018
est-ce que c'était finalement une
préparation pour le tour de france vous
allez en avoir six fils et une
préparation et souvent les étapes
du tour sont désignés alors que
un an deux ans trois ans avant
la ville a organisé paris nice par
exemple les starting blocks depuis deux
ans dans les startings de trois ans
alors nous allons maintenant revenir sur
l'histoire du tour de france dans les
yvelines mélanie poké journaliste chez
tv 78 vient nous présenter à cette
histoire du tour de france est une
longue histoire d'amour les yvelines et
tour de france et c'est une relation qui
débute dès la toute première édition en
1903 là on ne cherchait pas une vie du
département comme départ ou arrivée pour
cette édition le tour n'a que six étapes
alors le que et bien sûr entre
guillemets parce que l'étape la plus
courte parcours tout de même 2 168 km
mais ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
dernière le 18 juillet les coureurs
s'élancent de nantes et le 19 juillet il
se départageront sur les routes
sinueuses de la vallée de chevreuse et
là c'est maurice garin qui remporte et
l'étape et l'épreuve
alors si on s'intéresse juste aux villes
étapes le département a vu le peu le ton
emprunté ces routes à 46 reprises dont
24 rien que pour la ville de versailles
dès 1925 la grande boucle s'installe
dans les yvelines
la première étape est donné au vésinet
ville qui deviendra départ réel de la
course ensuite de 1927 à 1939
rambouillet l'accueillera à quatre
reprises saint germain en laye où ils et
mantes-la-jolie complètent le tableau
est à noter qu'en 1986 et une
agglomération qui voit arriver la
deuxième étape de l'épreuve une certaine
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qui sera le
départ de la dernière étape du tour en
2023 tout cela grâce à un partenariat
signé entre à etsaut l'organisaton
l'organisateur pardon de l'épreuve et le
département
il est signé en mars 2019 et quelques
mois plus tard la 21e étape de la grande
boucle s'est lancé de rambouillet le
maillot jaune était sur les épaules du
colombien et gagnent bernal alors le
dernier français à porter la tunique au
départ d'une étape yvelinoise c'est
laurent fignon en 1989 tunique qui
perdra malheureusement dans un final
tellement cruel sur les champs-elysées
l'année de ma naissance mais dany alors
merci mélanie pour ce panorama une belle
histoire d'amour entre les yvelines et
le tour de france finalement jean michel
avait sur oui absolument et une
une histoire fabuleuse et tout ça pour
dire que les yvelines c'est une terre de
cyclisme par excellence est une terre de
cyclisme qui va le montrer parce que les
le cyclisme les activités du cyclisme
les disciplines du cyclisme pour les
jeux olympiques se dérouleront dans les
yvelines bien sûr on va revenir sur ce
choix de chatou en 2021 qu'est ce que ça
apporte finalement à une ville
l'organisation du tour de france
l'organisation l'accueil soit d'une
ville départ on vit arriver où les deux
ce sont des retombées économiques que
formidable pour la ville et puis un
retentissement médiatique
parce que bon toutes les télés du monde
entier sont braqués sur cet événement
pays diffusent le tour de france 3 5
milliards de téléspectateurs sur
l'ensemble de la compétition
voilà c'est formidable et c'est vraiment
je pense le meilleur rapport qualité
prix
quand on veut faire connaître son
territoire donc d'accueillir le tour de
france c'est populaire également le tour
de france on l'a vu à mantes la jolie
en septembre dernier il y avait malgré
le contexte sanitaire énormément de
monde autour des routes oui parce que le
tour déjà c'est un spectacle gratuit
et puis on vire encourager des champions
on peut on peut les voir on peut les
approcher on est très près tout compte
fait en commune i avec eux on les
encourage
c'est le sport populaire par excellence
le cyclisme on va revenir sûr sûr sûr la
compétition aussi en elle-même il ya
deux cyclistes qui font énormément
parler d'eux en ce moment c'est gagnent
bernal et pogab chars deux jeunes
cyclistes de moins de 25 ans est ce
qu'ils seront également jaune l'année
prochaine dans les yvelines
c'est difficile à dire mais ils ne
seront pas les seuls parce que je pense
que la jeune génération a pris le
pouvoir et je pense qu'il y aura
également des jeunes comme mathieu van
der poule très prometteur le belge et
venez poule qui sera là et et d'autre
est également quelqu'un comme gaudu le
le breton gaudu qui s'est illustré la
semaine dernière sur une étape de
montagne et il jouera vraisemblablement
le classement général alors la jeune
génération je pense va prendre le
pouvoir
vous attendez un beau tour de france
2021 oui aussi beau que celui de 2020
celui de 2020 donc à garder le suspense
jusqu'à l'avant dernière étape et compte
tenu du tracé avec quatre étapes en
bretagne deux étapes
dans les alpes une grande étape avec la
traversée du morvan une étape qui
partira de vierzon jusqu au creusot la
traversée du morvan 248 kilomètres une
étape pour baroudeurs et après deux fois
le ventoux deux fois le mont ventoux
avec une arrivée à malaucène et
également de belles étapes dans les
pyrénées orientales est une étape qui
laquelle poux sera sûrement
ces parties de la décision finale c'est
une étape qui arrive en andorre avec le
port de l'envalira port d'envalira qui
sera le toit du tour de france 2004 108
m et puis également le 14 juillet
n'oubliez pas le 14 juillet ce sera une
étape phare avec l'arrivée au col du
portet une étape très difficile départ
de muret le porter et puis le dernier
contre-la-montre à saint-émilion
voilà mais ce sera sans aucun doute un
magnifique tour de france merci jean
michel richefort spécialiste cyclisme
merci mélanie pour toutes ces précisions
sur le tour de france 2021 la dernière
étape partira donc le 18 juillet
prochain depuis chatou on prend
maintenant la direction du chéné
rocancourt un village fondation psg
était installé ce mardi dans la vie
l'objectif de ce rendez vous organisé
par le club de la capitale proposer des
activités sportives gratuites pendant
ces vacances scolaires tout cela sur le
thème du club
reportage le village de la fondation psg
s'est installé aux chaînés rocancourt le
temps d'un après-midi créée il ya vingt
ans la structure propose aux enfants de
participer à des animations pendant les
vacances scolaires
350 opérations sont réalisées chaque
année par le paris saint-germain donc ce
sont des enfants qui ont entre 6 et 15
ans qui peuvent venir avec leurs parents
leurs grands frères leurs grandes soeurs
vraiment de partager un moment en
famille et on est on est sur des publics
qui n'ont pas forcément la chance de
partir et il reste pendant toutes leurs
vacances scolaires chez eux donc l'idée
c'est de leur propre leur proposer un
petit moment festif ce mardi 27 octobre
une douzaine d'animations étaient au
programme
on doit faire la deux on doit mettre fin
d'année il n'est pas niée
et si l'activité du football quel
maquillage ya les personnes
des activités sont issus de nos projets
éducatifs du socle pédagogie qui a la
culture des quatre stops et pédagogique
qui est la culture le numéro classique
et le sport l'histoire du club était
également présenté aux familles avec une
salle des trophées éphémère les anciens
joueurs du psg comme laurent fournier
avait également fait le déplacement
ça permet de revivre pour nos coûts des
bons moments pour les enfants de devoir
un peu que le pg a évolué la fondation
psg continuera à sillonner le
département pendant les prochains mois
chaque année vingt mille enfants
participent à ces ateliers et quitté son
confort pour se lancer dans sa passion
pour la course à pied c'est l'aventuré
choisi par frédéric supplié en ouvrant
sa boutique de course à pied à conflans
sainte honorine
une véritable aventure dans cette
période difficile pour les commerces
locaux son portrait par bixente mérian
santisteva après vingt ans de loyaux et
bon service dans la direction de
communication de plusieurs entreprises
frédéric suquet a choisi le pari de
l'entrepreneuriat pour cela rien de tel
que sa passion la course à pied il a
choisi d'ouvrir une franchise du magasin
et run à conflans sainte honorine
j'ai commencé la course à pied à l'âge
de 12 ans je suis fils d'un ancien
sprinteur qui a couru avec les meilleurs
français
je suis frère d'un marathonien qui a
fait partie des meilleurs français
également donc on est vraiment une
famille de deux coureurs on aime le
sport
l'ouverture de ce magasin fermé de
pouvoir allier ce désir d'entreprendre
et cette passion pour la course à pied
frédéric suc échos régulièrement depuis
de nombreuses années sur piste sur route
se testant même omar à tous son
expérience lui donne une expertise pour
conseiller ses clients proposent des
produits adaptés à la course à pied à la
marche indique en outre elle parce que
la force d'un magasin spécialisé comme
le mien le dicton d'autres
notre raison d'être c'est être
spécialiste ne s'invente pas quand on
vend des chaussures par exemple à un
client on lui vend en fonction de sa
morphologie en fonction de sa foulée en
fonction du terrain sur lequel il va
courir ce besoin de conseils est
d'autant plus justifiée qu'en france le
running devient une activité physique
très populaire la cour s'applique est
devenu vraiment un business qui marche
sans mauvais jeu de mots puisque au
début des années 2000 il y avait en
france à peu près de deux millions de
pratiquants
aujourd'hui on sait que les chiffes
tourne autour de 15 millions de
pratiquants en france
malheureusement pour le gérant le second
confinement le force à fermer ses portes
un paradoxe étant donné que le premier
avait fait de nombreux adeptes à la
course à pied et gens vont continuer à
courir le running et le sport enfin le
sport en plein air on va dire on n'en a
jamais autant entendu parler depuis
depuis l'apparition de ce virus
une décision difficile à accepter pour
le jeune entrepreneur qui doit également
interrompre les sessions de running en
groupe qui l'organisent devant sa
boutique tous les lundis soir et on
termine pas cette information aurélien
collin pourrait intégrer le panthéon du
football américain le footballeur
originaire de choses de
fontenay-le-fleury dans les yvelines
fait partie des cent trente sept
finalistes de la mls pour intégrer le
top 25 des meilleurs joueurs de
l'histoire du championnat
dans cette liste on retrouve notamment
david beckham valderrama thierry henry
ou encore zlatan ibrahimovic les votes
sont ouverts aux spécialistes et le
résultat sera dévoilé le 9 décembre
depuis ses débuts aux états unis en 2011
aurélien collin notamment été sacré
champion et mvp de la finale en 2013
avec kansas city le défenseur qui porte
le numéro 78 joue aujourd'hui à 34 ans à
philadelphie c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi le 7-8
sport se met en pause le temps du
confinement
mais le sport continue via notre talk si
on parlait sport on se retrouve bientôt
pour un nouveau magazine très belle
soirée sur tv 68
[Musique]